Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man over wings.
Liberty is such a wonder thing, behind us all come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for-
Ethiopia, every three of our crew, including yours, Lieutenant.
It's more likely because after the Triton encounter, they're not in any position to start hostilities, at least not for quite a time.
I trust that our government knows better than to take a General Grouchley at his word.
He is a monster of hypocrisy, you know.
You young people are right. I assure you we are aware of that on our guard.
But luck was on our side, and before long, our new fleet of ships will be ready.
That should calm them a little. I don't think they will start anything for a while.
For now, your next mission is waiting for you.
Maestro will brief you on the details. Listen carefully.
What? No, yes, yes. I'll tell you what we know so far.
This sun, the NGC 16612, is now approaching its decline, its end, soon to throw its final torrent of energy out into space.
However, soon it will change into a white dwarf star.
At present, it's beginning to fade.
What disturbs us in this is that this body here, the sun's fourth planet, until now, we were fairly sure that there was no life there.
It's true, we had observed a few slight changes in its aspect, but we attributed them to natural cycles.
Now, look, look, look, now, we're not too sure.
These, uh, how shall I say, these are distinct modifications coming from the interior.
Is there any sign of heat?
No, none at all. Anyway, none that we can detect.
So it can't be some seismic activity.
No, no, no, no. We don't understand.
It's just like some sort of dominion from within,
as if a troglodyte people suddenly decided to change its habitat in some radical way.
And if such a people exist, it's our duty to make contact,
to tell them that their planet is doomed,
and insofar as their own science hasn't already warned them.
Your companion has just worked out the last data on the fourth planet in the system NGC-16612.
Orbital distance, 137 million kilometers.
Planetary mass, 98.742 in relation to Earth.
Rotation, 30 hours.
Oxygen, 24.2%.
Hydrogen, 73.6%.
Argon, 0.6.
Carbon dioxide, 0.3.
In general atmospheric system, less than that of omega temperature.
Mild and constant with average of...
Wait, wait.
for me now as i was saying the ecology concerning the plants uh it's almost is everybody listening
to now never mind let's see a blow up here we go the view from here is exactly what we were led to
expect maestro was right let's try to make contact with the inhabitants let's activate magnetic
protection shield place looks deserted but it's standard procedure even in our air-conditioned
spacesuits it's hot let's check out that wall of vegetation over there twigs a few twigs i have
have just carried out a rapid analysis. It is indeed vegetation. I'd say they were giant trees.
Take a look. Their height, will you? They're really extraordinary. Well, sightseeing is over.
Let's go, let's go. Forgotten what silence is. Back on our planet, there's always noise.
Know that we're not all alone here, right? One big spike. Let me go inside this little bug on
stilts. Ultrasonic sounds to attract insects. Quite interesting, I must say. It's a strange
world. If all the inhabitants of this planet are that big, we're in for it. Strange world,
but also cruel down there we'll be safer we can set up our camp that's enough for one day tomorrow
will continue all right and to feel very tired let's rest here for a little while first
understand what's going on could it be that giant tree just behind us and once it's gone
where'd it go that's a magic trick yes i don't understand with certain vegetation it would be
possible for termites to cause such a thing but here with trees of this size do you realize how
How big the termites would have to be to devour that much terrifying.
Concerning termites, now somewhere in my memory banks, I have a very splendid story about termites.
Now let me see.
Food, storage, empty, houses, collapsing, furniture evaporating, um, oh, all sorts of things.
Dog!
Hey, what's wrong?
Yes, it was a nightmare. It was awful. It was because of Metro's story about termites.
Ah, so you're awake. Well, I have all the data on the soil now.
It is quite interesting. Did you realize that the soil contains...
Giant ants!
Substance found as a constituent in the shells of insects, found in spiders and lobsters, and also in membranes of certain mushrooms.
It looks as if the primordial soup on this planet was especially favorable to their evolution.
Let's get out of here. Come on.
This really does look like what Meister said we'd find.
Yes, it's like a fairy castle.
I wonder if anybody lives here.
It's a lot of a nightmare.
No way out of here.
Our insect friends are almost here.
Have to find someplace secure.
Okay, let's stay calm.
Let's think a little.
Even if they consider us nice, edible insects, it's hardly follows that all of them would call the whole army just for us.
You're right. They're coming for something else. But what?
If we're a termite, what would I want?
You got any ideas?
Well, a premeditated attack on us can't mathematically be considered likely.
Beyond that, I would need more data.
I do regret that. I'm only human. Nearly.
In the future, you must see to my programming, it is no pleasure for me to disappoint you.
Watch out. There they come. We're trapped.
Anything more that you would do?
You're going to get us without a good fight.
Metro, we need your laser!
You take care of the rear!
You can see it all from here!
Going for the termites!
They're protecting their own, tried some of their enemy.
They immediately considered us their friends!
And yet they know we're here, and it's all right with their series regularly.
You realize the work it took?
All this was constructed from the inside.
Ah, but then how do you explain the fairy-tale castles and all that's built outside?
I think they use the exterior as a sort of dumping ground for construction waste.
Interesting theory.
Stop there, see it?
Don't they eat?
Series aren't able to hold food, so they have to be fed.
You see? Watch. He just got a meal.
King, he's the only one that can fly.
Let's take a closer look at the queen.
Right in the middle of a colony of termites.
It's fascinating.
How do we get out of here?
Try to walk out the front.
Our old friends will start gnawing on us like two-by-fours and end up like toothpicks.
Interesting. Truly quite, quite interesting.
Yes, indeed. What organization?
If you will pardon the remark, they can't possibly do that without being programmed.
Programmed? Yes, in a way, I suppose.
But who did the programming?
They maintain an existence that's monotonous and unchanging,
carrying out their duties smoothly,
dedicated even to self-sacrifice.
We saw their soldiers in the face of the enemy.
It's as if they were obeying some higher will,
something beyond themselves,
or programmed to obey higher orders.
No, I admit it.
I don't understand what's going on here.
Will you allow me to give you just a few details, then?
It would appear that these charming creatures
go back to the primary era of just a hop, skip, and jump
back in time, so to speak, 250 million years.
A hundred million years later, with a little luck, the termites had, as playmites, our friends, the dinosaurs.
They can live only in tropical climate. Below 20 degrees centigrade, they perish.
Expose to direct rays of the sun, they perish.
Temperatures above 36 degrees, they perish.
They are host to certain bacilli, protozoan to be precise, which carry out their digestion and can attain half the weight of their host.
There are more than a thousand different varieties of termites.
The most numerous are the bellicoses and the insertas, as well as, well, if you aren't interested in these fascinating details, you have only to tell me now that termites have been known to act.
Celebrating their victory, or is it a religion?
What are they doing?
It's like a way we can get out of here.
The ants aren't going to be so friendly, though.
Okay, let's go.
Smetro, what's our exact position?
They are headed north, I would say, right under the...
Then we're headed in the right to get out of here, and right now.
Getting in the forest.
what's really interesting is they're being able to hollow out giant trees they can destroy and
digest entire forests oh that's very nice but we're still prisoners here we have to do something
they're born they live reproduce and die never having seen the light of day not us we haven't
looked down that way yet look let's go we might find a way out carrying the eggs out of that place
over there where they're stored let's go have a look see where they're coming from maybe we can
find a way out there were dangerous things could get if one day these things invaded our planet
You'll get it. One queen, okay. But three? Four?
Metro, can you explain it to us?
If I have analyzed the situation correctly, we are witnessing a hypertrophy reaction to the instinct to live in the face of imminent death.
Menaced? They reproduce as fast as they can. There we are.
We can see such a case in ancient history, which was nearly the same.
Then it concerned human beings in 1304.
Metro, that'll do it, okay?
We get the idea, thank you.
It makes sense. It's their solution to the problem Maestro described.
The sun, NGC 16612, is starting to go out.
Here, all the creatures sense that they're in great danger.
These fierce battles, this intense need to reproduce more of their kind, that's their answer.
An answer doubly wrong.
Wrong, since such activity will in no way prevent their disappearing when their planet cools.
And wrong, since such an increase in population can only result in a shortage of food.
One thing really bothers me here.
Who's in charge?
Whose orders are they following?
They don't have eyes or sex or wings.
I'd like to know why, for whom, are they doing all this?
What's motivating them?
A higher spirit, so to speak,
which can group these various functions and individuals
into a united home.
If you like, consider the human body
with its different parts and functions,
predetermined harmony, as Leibniz says,
or as Schopenhauer does,
these old notions going far back in prehistory,
then to certain modern philosophers.
Now, let's see.
Existence through function and process.
Yes, you're right.
You described it perfectly.
The harmonious functioning of independent elements to a coherent objective.
The kind of police patrols the whole region as the human body acting for the welfare of the whole body without requiring any guiding intelligence.
But here, everything is gigantic out of position.
Okay, let's see. We're inside some giant body.
We are accepted, tolerated, but prisoners within its confines.
And for us, making an incision in this body and getting out has now become a matter of life and death.
Patience, Pierrot. We're not its enemies, are we? We'll get out, you'll see.
We still have our weapons and we have Metro.
Make it this time. It's now or never for us to get out.
Edible places. Nothing is wasted, certainly not the excrement, which is the basis of all their food as well as of their building, very efficient.
Carbables.
Necrophied be the correct term, since they are certain that their fellow creature is quite dead before they eat him.
Okay, as I see it, all we have to do is ask Metro to direct his laser beam against a weak spot in the wall, and we'll blast a hole big enough for us to escape.
Yes, but Pierrot, that would be an aggressive action that we're allowed to take only in case of imminent danger.
You mean we're not in danger now? No food left? Lost in a labyrinth?
I suggest having a little look up on top. We just might find a way out.
Cut off the claws?
Considered food.
Yes, with all the rest. Population explosion. Food is where you find it.
Let's get out of here right now.
There has to be a way out of here, but that doesn't look like it.
Pierrot, I think we've had it.
Okay, this is it. We're getting out. Metro, into action.
Foreign body, an infection, something they have to eliminate.
Metro, give us the laser!
Do it one second.
Oh no, not...